elle ment à ce rendez vous crucial au
tour d'edouard philippe et d'olivier
verront des personnels des ehpad appelé
à manifester aujourd'hui et des
soignants qui manifestent également
devant l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil
dans le val-de-marne monae mood
alors vous êtes sur place quelle est la
situation mais le rassemblement semble
toucher à sa fin en tout cas ici devant
l'hôpital henri mondor
le personnel soignant des réanimations
des blocs opératoires des urgences mais
aussi d'autres services de soins se sont
joints ici pour porter haut et fort
leurs revendications à savoir une
revalorisation des salaires et des
meilleures conditions de travail
on le sait ces revendications elles sont
au coeur des mobilisations des hôpitaux
depuis des années déjà on se souvient de
cette mobilisation monstre juste avant
le confinement on a pu parler à ses
personnels soignants je vous propose de
les écouter on a porté aux efforts de
revendications
d'accord les personnels ici présents
arrive à se libérer pour descendre et
pourquoi je dis arrive à se libérer
parce que on est tellement influent
tendue que eux mêmes pour descendre dans
la rue et pouvoir exprimer leurs
revendications et nord et leur colère on
n'y arrive pas on arrivait au bout de
notre système
concrètement on est à saturation dans
les hôpitaux dans aux urgences on le
voit très bien nos collègues ont
manifesté
on fait grève l'année dernière
et en fait les urgences et la première
entrée c'est la porte d'entrée de
l'hôpital comme on dit mais sauf que le
problème que qu'à nos collègues des
urgences il est le reflet en fait du
problème hospitalier en général j'ai
attendu le concret qu'on nous donne le
concret des paroles des paroles c'est
bien beau depuis le temps nos salaires
ont été gelés depuis je ne sais combien
d'années ça n'avance pas
ça n'avance pas donc non on attend du
concret et cette journée elle n'a pas
été choisie au hasard puisque c'est
aujourd'hui que olivier vers on va
rencontrer les professionnels de santé
et tout cela en visio conférence bien
évidemment cette cette négociation alors
a pour but est bien de conditionner
d'apporter plus de solution aux
conditions de travail de tout ce
personnel soignant qui se mobilisent
déjà depuis des années comme je vous
l'avais dit et les annonces et bien
elles sont prévues pour la mi juillet
elles sont être très attendu merci mon
âme ou dès lors en direct de l'hôpital
henri mondor à créteil à